what you are voting on today
is momentous in terms of what it
represents
and in terms of what it secures
it represents the unity
responsibility and solidarity
within the european union to protect the
interests of our citizens
and our union firstly
this agreement protects european
citizens and their rights
second it protects european interest
and it preserves the integrity of our
single market
and it ensures high levels of protection
on
everything from social and labor rights
to environmental protection from tax
transparency
to state aid you name it it will give us
the tools we need
to ensure full and faithful compliance
with the obligations which both sides
signed up to
and it will also focus minds on finding
pragmatic solutions
where they are needed most urgently
around the protocol of ireland and
northern ireland we know it will not
always be easy and there is a lot of
vigilance
vigilance and hard work ahead of us
but while today's vote is obviously an
end
it is also the beginning of a new
chapter
you